welcome to this edition of just getting
started it is episode nine in our voices
of the nfl series please go to our
library and catch any of the episodes
that you may not have seen or heard
depending on if you're listening to this
on cumulus podcast network or watching
it on the rich eisen show youtube feed
al michaels joe buck
jim nance aaron andrews michael strahan
kevin harlan chris berman
last week the great amy trask
joined us as well um and now the only
guest in this series of ten who i went
to college with and the guy i've known
the longest of anybody that's been on
this
program and somebody for whom i actually
knew quite a bit about how he got
started but i want to bring that story
to you because i love this man he's from
the worldwide leader in sports formerly
my colleague at the nfl network my buddy
adam schefter what's up shefty rich
thank you for the kind words
congratulations on your saint jude's
thank you award over the weekend that
was awesome to watch that video well
deserving you've done so much good and
raised so much money for so many people
it's an honor to know you and to call
you a friend well you were there part of
that compound coverage where it was born
and you know the guy who was sitting
next to me very very well as well who
helped inspire it
because uh just like everything else out
of uh in the tv world
content if you will is uh born out of
sheer boredom waiting just waiting to
shoot something
and uh we were waiting to shoot total
access that night in the old rca dome
and the wii being me and tyrell davis
and i asked him how fast do you think i
can run the 40 and his answer was just
laughing i cursed at him and then ran
down and
ran the 40 and as you know they
surprised me by actually recording it
that night and i had no idea it was
being recorded
and all those children
millions and millions of dollars later
have benefited from in that and so
it's an awesome thing that's the
unintended consequences of life and
that's right you've done a mix for there
rich thank you sir i greatly appreciate
that i appreciate that okay so um this
pod's all about origin stories and
career origin stories and
i i know your career in a way got
started just like mine with the
outstanding student newspaper at the
university of michigan or alma mater the
michigan daily but did you always want
to do what you're doing right now
adam rich this is so far beyond anything
i ever could have and would have
imagined growing up and when we went to
michigan
the only reason
that i wound up working with you is
because i rushed to fraternity my
freshman year and there were 50 guys
going for about 10 spots and i was not
deemed worthy of a spot in this
particular fraternity so
i went down to the football office to
see if they needed somebody to pick up
jock straps and hand out water bottles
and they didn't need anybody and so i
went to the basketball office to see if
they needed somebody to clean the
lockers scrub the toilets do whatever
and they didn't need anybody and so when
the fraternity didn't want me and the
football office didn't want me and the
basketball office didn't want me and i
didn't know what else to do and i'm like
i got gotta do something what can i do
with my time here
let me try the student newspaper now i
went to michigan right with no
aspirations of wanting to work for the
student newspaper no idea that you could
even do that i just thought how cool
would this be where it gives me
a press pass right to go see these
events and talk to the athletes and be
around something that i've never been
around in my life
i went to michigan thinking like so many
jewish new yorkers i would go to
business school or law school and
somehow wound up with the student
newspaper right working with you
and so it was purely accidental if the
fraternity had taken me in if the
football office had given me a job at
the basketball office have given me a
job
i wouldn't be doing what i'm doing today
there's no way
well that that that is amazing that is
something i did not know that that's how
you got to michigan daily
um you know i i did stand up comedy in
college but
um i i just wound up at the student
newspaper just for similar reasons that
i i wanted to try and and get into
sports
you know because i i learned that at a
young age i couldn't hit the curve ball
or a jump shot right and and if i wanted
to get to a certain level of
of the sports world i probably had to
talk about it you know or write about it
well rich to me they they weren't real
jobs that that people did i i i know
that sounds weird but
the day that i was there was a day back
in march of 2012 where my high school
put me into its
ring of fame it's hall of fame whatever
you want to call it and steve levy the
voice of monday night football yes he
went to the same high school as me and
so they inducted us into the hall of
fame together on the very same night
yeah and
they asked us the origins of our careers
and i listened to steve levy talked
about how he grew up
wanting to do what he's doing how he did
an internship for wfan he did an
internship for a sports agent he did an
internship with another sports network
and i'm thinking holy moly like this guy
had it all figured out right and worked
right towards doing it whereas i am a
bus boy at hunan gourmet the chinese
restaurant scraping up cash so i could
go out with my friends on the weekend or
i'm
collecting carts at food town in america
new york to have extra money to take
girls out for coca-cola's like i never
thought about doing this
that isn't that is because that that
that's particularly remarkable because
i'll let everybody who's listening or
watching in on this
is you were a year before me
okay so i was a year behind you and you
were already established at the student
newspaper when i explained whatever that
means
no excuse me you were okay yeah you were
and the reason why i'm saying that is
not only because you were doing the
bigger sports beats than i was obviously
assigned to because that's the way it
worked at the student newspaper is you
started with the
non-basketball slash football correct
and then you graduated to that right
basketball your junior year and
obviously football being the senior year
and that's the way it would work at the
michigan daily but um you when i got
there were already
hooked up with the
greatest uh to do it maybe ever
in the state of michigan professionally
and mitch album
and i remember sitting there going okay
so you can not only
cut your teeth at this student newspaper
and express yourself
but start looking over the steering
wheel professionally
on on getting where you need to go in
this journalistic world
and you were the guy i'm like oh god
okay he's way ahead of the game already
in college and here but i wasn't but
here's the thing rich rich there was a
bar on the michigan campus called
dominic's that would give you a free
drink for every rejection letter that
you have i tell people forget about
getting a drink i could have owned the
bar i had that many rejection letters
right i mean it was crazy and yes
mitch album was somebody who when we
were in college
i idolized him i wanted to be
mitch album that was my dream my goal my
aspiration and when
during our scene my senior year he was
writing a book and he said hey i would
see him at these press conferences every
now and then i would talk to him and i'm
telling i worship the guy
he said i'm thinking about doing a book
would you be available to be
a research assistant i don't say my only
because she had a couple of people were
i'm like how much i have to pay you to
do that
and so i spent my senior year
gathering
beauchembechler anecdotes for him for
that but like that and honestly
i was taking my english classes my
science my math whatever it may be
history
i could care less about any of these
classes my goal my senior year was to
get as many boschem because stories as i
could back in the day like there were so
many of them and i would just type them
up and hand them to mitch
and you know he probably used just a
handful of them in his book but to me it
meant so much to be able to assist him
and work around him but when you're
saying that i was ahead of the game yeah
i'm not joking when i tell you that the
only reason i went to northwestern
graduate school the mcgill school of
journalism which you also went to
after me right yeah the only reason i
went there was because i couldn't get a
newspaper job
anywhere in the country not in
shreveport not in bismarck not in boise
not in los angeles not in any suburb
city you could think of and i sent out
hundreds hundreds of resumes cover
letters clips for the michigan daily
that maybe you might have even edited
back in the day like nobody would have
me nobody so when i had nothing to do i
went to graduate school
at the medieval school journalism right
as a matter just to before we move on on
that
did i edit your
your game story you didn't i told you
this no because for for the this is the
national championship game with glenn
rice one and all that you were not there
for that one you were not i was there
okay but i was there as a fan
and if you remember the way the michigan
daily worked was
the last beat that you covered was the
football beat of your senior year
football season ended january right so i
was done with the michigan daily
in january of 89
and michigan won the national
championship in basketball in april of
89 and i was a free and easy senior
looking for work figuring out going to
journalism school so i never sent in a
story because frankly i was with my
college buddies back in the day the
funny part is you could light up at the
athletic department get tickets to that
final four we got extra tickets scalp
some to pay for our trip to seattle
and flew out there
by scalping tickets we my friends and i
still joke about we walked into some
hotel room in seattle to meet some guy
that had cigars and can and beers and
and who knows what was going on in that
room like it was a crazy room we walked
in there what was the guy's name if i
texted one of my college roommates he
would know uh
and this guy was he had like stacks of
tickets it was seedy it was
it was it was awful and we sir here
here's your tickets and he gave us a lot
of cash and that lot of cash finance the
trip that we had to seattle which i
didn't write a game story because i was
so busy celebrating our school's
national championship in basketball
right and i was too busy swimming
upstream like a salmon down you know uh
sat you know down south university to
get to the student newspaper everyone
was rushing to the center of campus to
celebrate i drew the short straw to
close the newspaper that night so i left
my fraternity house to go close it but
again that's that's what we did in
college right with the student
newspapers we we we did realize it was
an endeavor it was also a labor of love
there's no question about it so i love
part of the story here adam because
obviously you're viewed by so many
people in the world of of the nfl and in
our entire industry is so remarkably
successful because you are
um and
the number of rejections that you got at
the start you said you know with a free
drink for each rejection letter you
could have owned an entire bar so
um
how how
how deep did it get for you before you
finally got your break i mean and when
did that happen
for you adam you know i i tell this to
college kids all the time that and i
think it's true whether you're going
into
our field or any field
unless you're some golden child and
there are a lot of them out there these
kids today are so impressive but
usually you're going to be met with all
sorts of rejections and all sorts of
blows to your ego you you got ahead very
early in the game rich your origins were
moonshot like right away okay okay so
and i i was not like that you know i've
just been the
the steady grinder my entire career
grinding away grinding away and letting
that go
where it will
and so
when i had all these rejections at
michigan that led me to graduate school
at northwestern where i sent out more
clippings and more resumes and got more
rejection letters
and then i got an internship
it's one of the great regrets of my life
still to this day is that
um i got an internship while i was at
northwestern and i was so excited and so
anxious
to get a newspaper job of any sort even
though it was a
internship at the seattle post
intelligencer
which is now defunct right the first few
papers i worked for the ann arbor news
the seattle post out of business you see
how important my contributions were to
their long-term success but anyway i
flew out to seattle and i said well when
do you want me to start and they said
june 25th and i said
okay and i didn't even think anything
else well graduation was like june 28th
three days later and i said you know
what that's the way it goes
and i never went to my graduation at
northwestern missed it because i went
out to seattle to start covering the
seattle mariners and goodwill games and
the very first day of my very first
assignment on my internship i walked
into the mariners locker room and i was
like a kidney candy store looking around
completely in awe and intimidated and
the very first person that walked up to
me
was
ken griffey jr
and
i knew exactly who he was back in the
day and he looked at me uh and he said
you look lost i said i i didn't know
what this i said my name is adam
schefter and he goes i'm gumby and i
said oh yeah okay and i just always
remembered that and i missed my high
school or my graduate school graduation
to go meet gumby in the mariners locker
room so the first athlete you
technically ever interviewed
professionally and well i never
interviewed him that well no no no no no
you you had a conversation
the first athlete that i encountered in
a locker room ever in my
professional versioning career at that
point in time was ken griffey jr and so
you know here's here here is the funny
part
when i was working for the seattle post
intelligencer the seattle times
had an opening covering high school
sports
and i wanted that job in the worst way
like
it meant everything i kept sending the
sports editor the seattle times all
these clippings
she never got back to me she never even
responded and i kept calling me i mean i
i must have reached out a dozen times
and so that was 1990 the summer of 1990
and
again it took me two full years before i
finally got my first offer it was
actually covering
uh preps for the los angeles times
suburban bureau like it was one of those
it was just something i'm like and i
went out celebrating in new york city
then i finally got an offer and when i
got back there was a note from my mother
laying on my pillow purple note i could
still say square note
barry forbus rocky mountain news 303
892-5326
called and it was the first time in two
years that a sports editor had called me
now i knew he wasn't calling me to say
hey how was your internship in seattle
right i was so excited and i called in
the morning said how fast can you get
out to denver for an interview i said
i'm coming right now got on the next
plane
flew out there took that job because
more it was more of a full-time job than
the los angeles times bureau high school
sports reporting job and started in
denver in september of 1990 at the age
of 23 years old so to me that was
that was like the first chance that i
had because i i i've never considered
myself talented in any one area but i
can tell you this
nobody
nobody wanted to be a sports reporter
any more than i wanted to be a sports
reporter at that point well no no no
no question you know and and you being
you know
that that's where you that that's where
it took off for you in denver colorado
and you know um
just to i guess dovetail everything here
so the summer of 90 that that's just
after i graduated and i got a call on my
graduation day at michigan
from the editor of my hometown newspaper
the staten island advance or as they say
in my hometown the staten island i got
rejected
but i was a summer intern there for
three years so they hire and i'm from
staten island so they you know they they
hired me i got a job right i walked
graduation with a job already secured
which was really remarkable right yeah
but but but
i wasn't cut out for news i i wanted to
be in sports i was absolutely not cut
out for news i've told this story on the
podcast earlier and i and i found out
exactly
you know why i wasn't when serious
stories came up i didn't want to you
know i was trying not to cover it and i
was trying not to
you know i i wasn't cut out to ask the
tough questions you know about life you
know
and um life or death when somebody's
murdered or somebody's house is burned
down like i just didn't want to do that
i wanted to get in the toy department
which lou prado the great professor at
mcdill school of journalism would call
the sports department at any rate um so
i realized two years three years and i
wanted to do sports tv and
when i was kind of
not
i i i knew i couldn't make my own tape i
had to get my own tape and the only way
out for me i thought to get started was
to go to the madill school of journalism
and part of the reason why i went is
because
you had already gone there and you had
already been successful i'm telling this
for the truth and then when i got out of
madill and i started road tripping
around
upstate new york and also in parts of
massachusetts and connecticut to try and
look for a job
and i remember i was going to
visit keith olbermann for an
informational interview with him at espn
because an internship that i took at cbs
evening news the guy who was the
executive producer eric sorenson new ko
and he hooked me up so i'm driving
from albany where i had just gotten
rejected in the worst possible way
through to espn and i stayed overnight
in some hotel motel
and i turned on sportscenter
and there was a piece about the
burgeoning denver broncos team this is
in 94.
and um and and an old college friend
appeared on on the piece
as a pundit talking about how great the
broncos were
and it just kind of put me in a terrible
funk i'm like he's so far ahead and i'm
sitting in a fleet bitten motel and that
person was
you
well well hold on i'm telling you adam
it just it it it definitely was like you
were like if you can do it i can do it
that's the way i thought
just to dig myself out
and you know so you're telling me that
that if if i could do it at the michigan
daily you could do it if i could have a
deal you could do it if i could appear
on espn you could do it so in a way yes
i blazed the path for you
you know what you could be facetious all
you want and and the funny thing is is
you is you're like you didn't have it
all together you know in college and you
were just running quotes for an album
and you were you know scalping tickets
and whatever but you we were all viewing
you as like you had it together like you
knew what you were doing because because
you were of singular
focus
that's true that you were and it was so
obvious you were like this is what i'm
gonna do and i'm gonna freaking do it
and
and then you did
and that's the truth
and that's well that's something that's
definitely something yeah but rich
i mean
it's an unbelievable thing to think
about i think back now when to hear you
tell a story and i remember hearing
about you
you were in stockton california what
where
reading california right
writing's beautiful but yeah but i
remember you doing that and then getting
tsp like oh my god look at rich i look
at what rich is doing holy rich is
killing oh my god look at rich that's
unbelievable and so that's an
inspiration to all the people who worked
around you at college right and so maybe
we all need some sort of inspiration and
we derive it at different points in our
life
and and try to find it and and i
honestly
uh didn't think or know that i provided
any of that ever to you because i was so
busy
scrambling right desperate to make my
way in a business that was so
hard to break into that meant so much to
me that i gave everything to to try to
get into and even when i got to denver i
don't know anybody in denver i move out
there 23 i pour myself into the job i
pour myself into that beat and i always
tell people and this is true
you know i went to michigan undergrad i
went to northwestern graduate school but
i feel like i got my master's at denver
broncos u like it was 15 plus years of
covering that team and understanding how
a football organization works and
getting to know all the people that were
there who then branched out to other
places and
i didn't go to nfl network rich
until i was
38 years old so you're on tv you're a
star you become all i was was a
newspaper
beat reporter right almost 16 years
grinding away and in my mind
i thought that that was something that i
was going to do the rest of my life and
i was completely comfortable with that
like i loved covering that team and at
that point in time nobody had ever
covered that team
which is religion in denver
as long as i had covered that team and
so to me that was my great badge of
honor until i moved on to work with you
before you at nfl network that was i i
remember where it was it was at the
breakers hotel in um in palm beach
florida at the owners meeting in 2004
and you were there because you were
covering it
and i remember it was like we you know
the network was like we need somebody
to find out stories break news and be
our information reporter
and i remember it was you know at the
time the executive producer eric
weinberger and bornstein steve bornstein
yep um saying you know we're looking at
a guy in denver he says he knows you i'm
like who is adam schefter like i spit
the words out because i knew you know
there's only one guy in denver who knew
me right and um from college and i'm
like oh my god and i remember walking
across
like some sort of you know party or
get-together that the league was
throwing and you were there and the two
of us started talking
and uh of course you know i'm like that
this should be the beginning middle and
end of the discussion
and then just so so the fact that i was
part of something totally new that was
so crucial to my career after having you
know departed espn
and then you
are now part of something like that it
is crucial cross
you know section it really was like you
can't make this [ __ ] up you know like
you cannot yeah make it up
and that's you know and everyone's like
so you and adam like you guys got a
rapport i'm like
you know
you know you were always very talented
very talkative very funny very engaging
i was a grinder
and we managed to just come and and that
because i don't know anything else
because i don't feel like i have you
know i'm capable of doing much else
other than grinding away so now
obviously you're still at the worldwide
leader and now i am where i am so i
guess last two questions for you because
um not only do i know you've got you
know more to do but i also know you adam
i noticed a couple times and this is how
terrific you are at what you do uh how
many times over over under i'm gonna
take the i'm gonna take the over
of you checking your phone during this
conversation while still holding a
conversation and being engaging uh the
over under is two and a half i'm gonna
take i'm gonna take the over you've done
it three times during this conversation
or is it four how many times three times
three times okay
and for people who are are listening
would they know that that happened see
my wife is used to this and she can't
stand it or me right like
you gotta do that you're not there again
but no
this is what i i've trained myself to do
over the years that that is a talent i
can text and look down as i'm talking
and listen and talk i mean it's
incredible seriously i mean it's really
it's a talent so two things where do you
get the grinder mentality from i mean
because again there are many people who
listen to this
podcast and this is the the listeners i
i appreciate
um
very much that you know that's the
reason why we started this podcast is
somebody's trying to get started on
something new and
the the whole mantra of this is that you
do have it within you to get started you
know belief itself don't take no for an
answer etc but where do you get that
from it's a very deep question and it's
a very personal question
and um
you know i'd have to i'd have to really
stop and think about my immediate
reaction would be that
i feel like i never grew up with a whole
lot
you know um i feel like i never had like
i'm just being honest with somebody's
talents that some of these people are
blessed with like
like yourself
and so
to make up for that i figured okay well
there may be smarter people funnier
people
people who can converse better
i'm gonna
try to outwork everybody and i guess
that's really it like and i'm gonna try
to outwork people to
um try to provide a life and some of the
things that i've never had in my life
um
so i i guess that's kind of it rich you
know growing up in belmore long island
south shore
belmore jfk high school uh
believe me it was not depraved childhood
no but it was not something where um
you know
my parents uh were very giving and gave
themselves but
i just i just to me that's the way you
do it you there's a professional
responsibility
uh to give of yourself
and to
give everything you have to a job
and and i i just feel like
that's the thing that i can bring to the
table like i'm proud to say to you that
nobody wanted to do this any more than i
did no there's no way like there i'm
sure there are a lot of people i'm sure
that really want to do this but
i lived at eid it eat it
ate it breathed it
and it it it meant
everything to me to the point where you
know i don't get married till i'm 40
years old because i was so
immersed in the job and while my friends
are traveling the world and getting
married and having children and raising
families
i'm covering the denver broncos i'm at
the facility on thanksgiving i'm at the
facility on christmas i'm at the
facility on weekends i'm talking to
players i'm writing books like i was
just thrown into it
and it it always meant a lot to me it
still means a lot to me
um
and and
i guess
that's the only way i know how to do it
and now you got a daughter on
nickelodeon talking football oh my god
that that's
yeah she uh she was on there last night
with austin eckler she mark andrews the
week before and i like to say
um
and you know and i'm proud of this that
uh
she's had better guests than i've had on
on the adam schefter podcast by a
landslide because you know what i help
her i try to help when i can round up
certain people and nickelodeon's done a
great job with it um shawn robbins
outstanding but
i would much rather her have
tom brady than me have tom brady on my
podcast so now that that's begs
and then i got one more last question
you know but but this begs this one
though follow-up
has your daughter
given you a nugget of information that
you did not know that you were able to
follow up on
has that happened yet adam hey dad you
know what i just found out okay because
she doesn't know she's more into what
they're doing you know what they're
dressing up for on halloween what are
they giving out although i i will say
like little things that she had jamar
chase on earlier this year and uh right
and he said his nickname was uno
and and she's like why uno
and he said because
my birthday's on the first my parents
birthday's on the first my brother's
birthday's on the first everybody's
birthday oh my god that's kind of
interesting now i'm not gonna have that
as one of the headlines on some of the
nfl countdown but i thought well that
that's very interesting well let me
follow up with let me follow this adam
then because on game day morning this
past weekend yeah you know a line that i
used
in a lead-in for the bengals was that
they've gone from ocho cinco of
yesteryear
to the present and future of uno
yeah now i had read that somewhere that
his nickname was uno could it be
possible yes
that could be your daughter i never
heard that before got it out
and i was right there when she was doing
the interview with him
and he goes into this whole uno
explanation
and i thought to myself well that that's
pretty good that's pretty good maybe
your daughter
helped filter something into my copy
before yours that is
come on now that's what college friends
are all for right there it's
unbelievable right i know i love it so
last one for you i ask all my guests as
a final question best piece of advice
you've ever received and from
who
would that be in your career
yeah oh boy i i don't know that there
you know i listen um
there's nothing that strikes me right
away okay uh and and and i'm not any
great philosopher or anything like that
but i would say i'd rather lean on
myself there
and say to all the people looking for
advice
you can go do anything you want i never
realized that growing up if you want to
be president of the united states why
can't you be you want to be the general
manager of football team why like i've
i've talked to them
you can do that
you can be that like i didn't know this
rich
i didn't know this when we were at
michigan like you could really go into
this profession you could cover sports
for a living you could go do anything
you want and again
i don't know my parents
helped send me to michigan
gave so much to
get me but but for some reason i never
learned
growing up online that you can do
anything you want in this life
and and that's that that's the advice
that i would have for people pretty
simple pretty basic almost cliched right
but there's nothing that instantaneously
comes to me there was no thunderbolt
that mitch album or rich eisen or anyone
that we ever worked with at the jeff
rush at the student newspaper gave me
back in the day
[Music]
that stayed with me
other than just go bust your ass
try as hard as you can
and
see where it goes
you're the best adam schefter thanks
again pal
love you too we'll we'll chat again soon
that's adam schefter right here on just
getting started the voices of the nfl
edition of just getting started great
message from my buddy schefter adam
schefter um there's so many
tremendous people in this business who
do
um
what so many fans of the nfl require
which is to find out the insatiable
desire to find out what's going on you
know um my my buddy ian rappaport from
the nfl media group jason lachenforo was
before him and after adam schefter at
the nfl network wherever
you want to
take in your information was doing it at
espn for so many years when adam joined
espn and that was one of the more
crushing blows of my nfl network career
is when adam departed
um and and went to espn um
it was just a a blast to work with uh a
college buddy in something that was just
getting started for me which was nfl
network and
you know there there's there's
i should cover this ground um before
wrapping up with adam's message
uh on this podcast i haven't spoken yet
about leaving espn for nfl network
and telling that story so i'll do it
here
so many people are always asking me
why'd you leave espn well
you know the intent was never to leave
espn i mean that was my dream job to get
to sportscenter in 1996 at the zenith of
sportscenter pretty much when
kilbourne was there and keith and dan
were there and doing the uh big show and
robin roberts and
and bob lee and and charlie steiner and
then i was there with stuart for all
those years and
you know um and so much more uh there
was never an intention to leave but
sportscenter changed um from a show
about telling you what
happened
to why something happened and the reason
why that changed is because of you know
your phones and
and the computers that that would get
you your information and espn management
assumed that you would know what had
happened
prior to turning on sportscenter
um
you know in in 2001 the bottom line
ticker started appearing on the bottom
line of your television screen revealing
scores
of of a of a game that i was just doing
a highlight of trying to reveal the
result to you it kind of cannibalized
what i was doing and then instead of
being a a host of a of a
highlight-driven show i was now the host
of a show with two analysts coming on
argue about why something happened
crossfire on cnn was a big show and i i
just didn't want to do sportscenter as
much anymore i was doing about 125 of
them
it's a dream job i i'm not telling
anybody it's not it's a dream job to do
that show and certainly at the time i
was doing it it was a total dream
the intention was never to leave but
like i said the show changed i wanted to
do more material
um at um
at espn which was now owned by disney i
wanted to do more shows i wanted to do
more have more opportunities and the
management team there was unwilling to
uh endeavor that i was offered the
original uh hosting role of the show
called cold pizza if you remember that
show
in 2003 it launched in new york city
which is another reason why i wanted to
do it i wanted to live in new york as
opposed to central connecticut
just getting i was just getting married
to my uh wife
um 18 years ago
um in 2003 and so the idea appealed to
me but the show was just not
fully formed and it wasn't something
that i thought would last and it didn't
actually um it morphed into first take
as you know that's where skip bayless
first appeared on espn on cold pizza and
then he
started doing first take from there
so long story short though i i i i had
no intention to leave espn but espn
wasn't affording me the opportunities
that i
i wanted
so i stuck to my guns i'm like i think i
can do more than just a um a morphed
highlight-driven show i wanted to call
games i wanted to do
more interviews i wanted to do
uh other appearances i asked to be on
good morning america actually and
just as if they needed somebody to talk
sports there and interestingly enough i
was told
that uh you know i was not allowed even
that opportunity
and now uh strays on that show
and so is robin roberts
as well doing just incredible work so
at any rate um nfl network came calling
i also had an opportunity to call braves
games for
tbs and work for turner they knocked on
my door as well
and the incredible team there was so
professional and so exciting to be
thought of as somebody that could be
a voice of their changing braves
coverage
and they wanted to get a different
announced team in there and reached out
to me
eventually did move on from their
announced team their longtime announce
team at tbs and
and um i decided to
follow
my my voice and my inner gut
and move to los angeles and work for
steve bernstein the longtime president
of espn who had left and
and was working at nfl network
um and the nfl to launch nfl network and
work on their broadcast strategies and
he reached out to me and offered me a
job and
um it was between that and and
um
going to work for turner and honestly i
sat there and i thought like you know
ernie johnson's a turner
um
and he's their
guy and i could go out and start
something new all of my own
and also i just got married i didn't
really want to be on the road for a
10-game road trip like three in colorado
four and you know
chicago
three in cincinnati like how do i just
get started on my life and um as a
married man
you know my wife was willing to you know
have me do that
you know i mean we were willing to to
figure it out
but i just didn't feel right
doing that
so i wanted to just get started on
something new
with you know
the nfl and that was kind of an educated
guess that you know kind of good to bet
on the nfl and i wanted to get started
on my life as a married man and
now a father of three
so that's why i did that all that and it
was tough
it was tough you know going from the
platform of espn and sportscenter to
cutting it in by 90 i mean espn was in
over 100 million homes and nfl network
was in 10 million homes and it was
starting up it was new and
it was um
amazing and obviously the opportunity is
completely worked out and i'm happy for
it but so many people ask me why
and that's essentially why you know i
wasn't being offered the opportunities
that i wanted
and i wasn't um
you know um
considered by management as uh
multi-dimensional
that i could do all that that they
weren't willing to feed my um
my desire to branch out and bet on me
and um and actually try to make an
example of me that anybody who was doing
sportscenter had to do just that
clearly that that that's changed now
but um
it was uh
it was something else man
and it was it was a a long slog because
i was getting married in the middle of
it but the reason why i bring all of it
up is
you know um
adam wound up there and we got to meet
each other
and
you know part of the reason why we get
along so well is we do have a similar
desire and singular focus about
getting a job done
you know and focusing on
on trying to make
an opportunity come true
and his
very simple mantra of you can do
anything
that you put your mind to you can you
can believe in yourself just whatever
you want to do go chase it down you know
and he said it's cliche but it's true
that's what i thought of with espn
you know i wanted to do more than just
was being afforded to me after seven
years
and i decided to risk it
so
you know no risk get no biscuit as bruce
arians of the tampa buccaneers has to
say
and um that's what adam was talking
about that's what i did to go from
nfl network espn to nfl network and
that's what he did to go from nfl
network to espn
you know he wasn't getting what he
wanted or given an opportunity to do
what he wanted to do outside of
of um
of what what they thought he only could
do i mean adam as you know is
actually now doing sidelines of nba
games so and so much more a podcast etc
so that's just a simple message i just
wanted to echo um this uh 10-part series
of the voices of the nfl
season 2 edition of just getting started
wraps up next week with the great chris
collinsworth kind of bookends al
michaels is our first chris collinsworth
will be our 10th and final guest of the
voices of nfl series so check that out
and our entire archive where all
podcasts are gotten right here through
the cumulus podcast network
that's it for this edition of just
getting started